IN.
CHARLES?
>> Charles: THANKS, MIKE.
IT WAS SO AMAZING TO ME THAT
THEY MADE THIS MOVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THIS WAS THE IDEAL CANDIDATE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN PICKED HIM IN
PART BECAUSE HE PUSHED BACK
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
POLICIES.
DO YOU FEAR IT MIGHT BECOME EVEN
MORE OF AN INDIFFERENT APPROACH
FROM WASHINGTON'S POINT OF VIEW?
>> ABSOLUTELY, CHARLES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT, CHARLES,
THIS IS NOT GOING TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES WHATSOEVER TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING UNLESS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AT THE TOP
LEVEL, WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE
ANY CHANGES WHATSOEVER WITH THIS
BORDER CRISIS.
UNLESS THE CURRENT LEADERSHIP
ENACTS POLICIES THAT WERE
WORKING PRIOR TO 2021, WE MIGHT
SEE A CHANGE.
UNTIL THEN YOU SEE IT FROM THE
FOOTAGE AND FROM THE
CORRESPONDENTS IN THE FIELD.
THIS IS NONSTOP.
IT'S ON A CONSISTENT BASIS AND
WON'T SLOW DOWN.
UNFORTUNATELY UNLESS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE, WE'LL SEE
THIS THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
>> Charles: CHRIS, DO YOU THINK
IF THE RED WAVE, IF IT
MATERIALIZED, COULD THERE HAVE
BEEN MORE PRESSURE IN WASHINGTON
D.C.?
>> WELL, I THINK IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BENEFICIAL.
WOULD HAVE PUT MORE PRESSURE ON
THE CURRENT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AGAIN, UNTIL WE SEE A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN LEADERSHIP
AT THE TOP LEVEL, WE'RE NOT
GOING SEE ANY POLICY CHANGES
WITH ANYTHING RELATED TO THE
BORDER.
YOU HEARD IT FROM BORDER PATROL
AND BRANDON JUDD WHO SAID IT
HIMSELF, THIS COULD BE EASILY
FIXED IF THEY WOULD ENACT THE
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING PRIOR
TO 21.
UNTIL THEN, WE'LL SEE MASS
MIGRATION AND FENTANYL POURING
ACROSS.
SOME OF THE IMMIGRANTS ARE
LOSING THEIR LIVES AT RECORD
LEVELS AND THE KNOWN GOT-AWAYS.
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
UNLESS THERE'S A CHANGE AND
SOMEONE PUTS THE POLICIES IN
PLACE.
>> Charles: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE, WHY
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
I WAS READING WHERE OPERATION
LONESTAR BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY THERE HAS
RECOVERED 350 -- IS THIS NUMBER
RIGHT?
350 MILLION LETHAL FENTANYL
DOSES?
IS THAT NUMBER CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT, CHARLES.
ONE THING THAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT
THAT AMOUNT OF FENTANYL SEIZED,
THAT IS FENTANYL THAT IS NOT
SEIZED AT THE PORT OF ENTRY.
IT MADE IT PAST THE PORTS OF
ENTRY, INSIDES VEHICLES
CONCEALED AND OUR STATE TROOPERS
ARE OUT THERE WORKING THE
HIGHWAYS, MAKING THE CORDONS AND
SEIZING THE DRUGS.
THAT'S A VERY UNIQUE NUMBER, A
STAGGERING NUMBER.
IF IT WASN'T FOR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN OF DPS OUT THERE STOPPING
THESE CRIMINALS, STOPPING THE
DRUGS COMING ACROSS, WE WOULD
SEE MORE FENTANYL COMING ACROSS
INTO OUR COUNTRY, MORE HUMAN
SMUGGLERS.
MORE AMERICANS ARE DYING BECAUSE
OF THE DRUGS.
IF IT WASN'T FOR OPERATION LONE
STAR, THE NUMBERS WOULD BE MORE
STAGGERING THAT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
COULD GET WORSE.
IT COULD IF IT WASN'T FOR OUR
MEN AND WOMEN OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE COST, THE
HUMAN TOLL ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER, THE GET AWAYS, THE
DRUGS.
ENTICING FOLKS TO MAKE THIS
TREK, PARTICULARLY YOUNG WOMAN
ALONE TO THE COYOTES, THE DRUG
LORDS.
IT'S MIND BOGGLING THERE'S NOT A
SERIOUS SENSE OF URGENCY HERE.
WHAT HAPPENS ON YOUR END FROM
HERE?
>> WE THOUGHT WE WOULD SEE A
CHANGE WITH THE HAITIANS IN
DEL RIO.
53 IMMIGRANTS LOST THEIR LIVES
IN SAN ANTONIO.
NOTHING WAS ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE STATE OF TEXAS HAS TO FILL
IN THE GAPS.
THERE'S SO MUCH ACTIVITY TAKING
PLACE THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE NOT AWARE OF.
WE'RE TRYING TO SHOWCASE AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE AND ALSO WITH THE
REPORTING THAT YEAR DOING HELPS
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND IF WE HAVE TO DO THIS THE
NEXT TWO YEARS, WE WILL.
SOMEONE HAS TO DO IT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO